what is up everybody it's axel here for
anime uproar and as you know
that means we have another jujutsu
kaizen video since we covered special
grade sorcerers in our previous video
today we'll be discussing their
counterparts in these special grade
curses
if you enjoy this video and want to see
more jiu jitsu kaizen content on this
channel be sure to leave a like and
maybe consider leaving a comment with
what you'd like to see me talk about
next
it will only take a second but it's a
huge help to the channel
and hey if you haven't subscribed to
anime uproar make this the video that
you do so by clicking the bell
and selecting all notifications finally
you can also follow anime uproar on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
or you can follow myself at excellionyt
of course this video will contain jiu
jitsu kaizen manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned also speaking of
the manga it will be returning this
weekend so look forward to a chapter
review here on anime uproar to keep you
up to date with the events of jiu jitsu
kaizen
with all that out of the way let's get
into the video
so while we've seen a bunch of what i
consider to be weaker
special grade curses this video will
focus on the 4 special grade curses in
ghettos gang
being mahito jogo hanami and dagon
the curse wound trio being chozo eso and
kechizu
and then we'll finish up with the
vengeful spirits like
curse rika tomino no maya
i realize that this isn't all of the
special grade curses that we've seen so
far but let's be real
a lot of them just aren't all that well
special of course all special grade
curses are pretty powerful with the
general descriptor of them being that a
cluster bomb
might be able to deal with them but when
it comes to
the less relevant ones there tends to
just not be a whole lot to talk about
because they were dealt with
so quickly or they're just so bare bones
the only two that i'm going to touch on
in this video will be the finger bearer
and the smallpox deity they aren't
particularly special but they at least
do play some role in the story so i'll
talk about them quickly
the finger bearers are curses which have
consumed one of sukuno's fingers
this makes them much stronger than they
would have been otherwise and it also
allows them to create incomplete domains
however that's kind of the extent to
them honestly
i consider them to be the floor of the
special grade cursed here
yes they're strong but they don't really
have that special
part of special grade curses we also had
these smallpox deity this curse fought
against meimei and while it didn't
really last
that long it was definitely a very
interesting curse
using a domain expansion it would
continuously trap its target in a coffin
and force them to escape before they
were crushed by a tombstone
if they were crushed they would be
infected with smallpox
i like this for a lot of reasons but the
main one is that it's so ridiculous and
over the top that it managed to get me
to be even more invested in the fight of
course this also meant that this was one
of the few curses we've seen use a
domain expansion
but yeah now that the small fries are
out of the way let's get into the meat
and potatoes
four of the more relevant special grape
curses are the ones that we see working
directly with ghetto
jogo is probably the most
straightforward and easy to deal with so
let's start there
jogo is kind of this crotchety old man
curse who looks like a cyclops with a
small volcano on his head
kind of like that episode of spongebob
where squidward became a superhero
and as you might imagine based on his
looks he has mostly
fire based abilities his innate ability
is called disaster flame which allows
him to generate and control volcanoes
anywhere he pleases within a range
however for smaller enemies he might
create small exploding insects which he
can launch at targets
or if the enemy is a real threat he can
use maximum meteor to create a massive
fireball that as the name suggests
resembles a meteor finally of course
jogo has his domain expansion
coffin of the iron mountain which brings
him and his opponent into a massive
volcano
in which he can control all of the lava
and rock
mahito is a patchwork looking man with
stitches
all over his face and body while most of
the curses
we've seen are kind of indifferent to
human lives they don't usually really
care one way or another if they have to
kill them
majito is obsessive about collecting and
experimenting on humans which
i think makes him one of the most
dangerous and definitely one of the most
creepy curses in the series this is
supplemented when you take into account
his innate technique
idol transfiguration this effectively
allows him to morph the soul of anything
he touches
and by doing so he can change their body
into whatever he wants
this can be used to heal clone himself
or transform part of himself into a
weapon
all of that pretty damn cool where it
gets a little bit on the nightmare side
is that he often uses this to experiment
on people shrinking them down
turning them into withered husks or
expanding them to the point where they
can be used as a small bridge
worst of all they live through all of
that and experience it
so yeah mahito a little bit disturbing
this of course
isn't the limit of mahido's abilities
though he can merge souls together
create transfigured humans who are kind
of like zombie monsters
and finally he has instant spirit body
of distorted killing
which was basically his level up after
finding the essence of his own soul he
became much stronger
and gained a much scarier body to match
speaking of a scary body let's take a
look at
haunami hanami is this giant
white-skinned curse with black markings
all over his body
and branches coming from his eyes to
form horns
his ability is disaster plant which
allows him to create manipulate and
control nature
typically working with wood roots or
plants
to attack or bind his opponents he can
also make any of his creations vanish
instantly whenever he wants which can
make fighting him very tricky
his other abilities include shooting
cursed buds into his enemies which will
grow inside of them and deal damage when
they use cursed energy
and if honey wants to stop a fight he
can create a flowery field
in which a mass of pedals will float up
and remove the enemies will to fight
finally hanami also has an insane
healing ability that can keep up with a
ton
of damage and finishing up our quartet
is the villain from pirates of the
caribbean dead man's chest
i refuse to call him dagon his name is
now davey jones
you cannot convince me otherwise so
don't bother trying anyways as you might
expect of davy jones all of his
abilities have to do with water and
piratey stuff
although admittedly we haven't really
seen that much of him
his innate ability is called disaster
tide and it allows him to create a ton
of water and sea monsters
all of which can be manipulated or
controlled at least at some level
he can also use his domain horizon of
the captivating skanda to create a
beautiful beach that he can just kind of
chill and relax
on or i don't know launch a never-ending
swarm of sea monsters at his opponents
until they devour them whole
just like in pirates of the caribbean
our next group is the cursed womb death
painting trio
each of which have a very strong sense
of family which is kind of a neat detail
the cursed wombs are an interesting
topic in themselves
so if you want a video on them in the
future be sure to let us know in the
comments
of all of the cursed wombs we're only
going to be focusing on the death
painting trio
these being ketchizu esso and chozo
kechizu and eso are the ones who battled
yuji and nobara
at the end of season 1 in the anime each
of these two have
similarities in that they use rotting
based abilities however physically
they aren't exactly twins esso looks
like just a run-of-the-mill buff dude
with the exception of a horrific
truly terrifying face on his back
meanwhile kechuzu is well
i don't even know how to describe this
guy other than saying he's a mix of
gluttony from fullmetal alchemist
and mike wazowski from monsters inc but
in the worst way
each of their abilities focus around
rotting away anything that's touched by
their blood
however esso is more powerful potent and
has more options
these include being able to shape his
blood into simple wings
which will give him a little bit of
extra mobility or to attack from a
distance
regardless though once the target has
been infected with the toxic blood
esso is able to activate decay which
puts both a beautiful design on the
affected area
and basically puts that person's life on
a very short timer
their abilities are honestly very simple
but hey it's still made for a damn good
fight the eldest of the three brothers
is chozo and he is easily the most
powerful of
all of them while also looking much more
human than his siblings
to begin with chozo doesn't seem to have
any of the toxic or rotting properties
that his brothers had
instead he's just an extremely talented
user of blood manipulation this of
course allows him to control his own
blood
his most common technique with this
involves cupping his palms together to
make a funnel with his fingers and then
firing off blood in either shots or
streams at incredible speeds and with
devastating force
it is much more versatile than that
though he can also make knives from the
blood and then
rotate the blood within it to
effectively make a very small scale
chainsaw
he can also change his own blood's
composition raising the red blood
cells body temperature and his pulse to
become faster
and stronger making him basically go
gear second
or he can harden his blood and launch it
with black meteor for
some devastating damage and finally that
brings us to our imaginary vengeful
spirits
let's start with who is probably the
strongest of the group being sukuna
as the king of curses sukuna is about
as strong as you would think currently
he is more or less being held within
yuji but who knows how long that's going
to last
especially considering his binding bow
but at the end of the shibuya incident
we got a short glimpse of
tsukuna really letting loose and that
was
insane watching him absolutely toy with
jogo
and then taking down maharaga was
incredible
most of sukuna's abilities revolve
around slashing
and this comes in two flavors dismantle
which is just a normal
everyday slash for regular objects
and cleave which automatically adjusts
to become more powerful against
opponents with cursed energy
or against things which are more durable
having both of these
essentially ensures that he can almost
always one-shot whatever he's fighting
but let's say we have to fight something
nearly invincible like maharaga
here he can rely on his domain expansion
malevolent shrine
this creates a 200 meter radius that
constantly slashes at
everything within it that said there is
no barrier around it so
someone could technically escape if they
could manage to run fast enough
that is the trade-off for having this
massive range on this domain
now on top of this while every other
character so far only has
one innate ability available sukuna
seems to have a second one as he also
managed to use flame-based attacks as
well
oh and he can use his reverse curse
technique to regrow limbs
revive yuji from being dead after his
heart removed
you know simple things like that and
since we just had the king of curses
let's move on to the queen
rika orimoto was childhood friends with
yuta
before she was hit by a car and after
dying she was
cursed this led her to becoming curse
rica a spirit with immeasurable cursed
energy
that can take the shape of any cursed
technique when manifested
she is ungodly strong and can rip apart
massive spirits with ease also and this
one
is a little bit strange but after a show
of great devotion and dedication from
utah
rika is able to shoot a beam of pure
love
which is apparently the strongest curse
of all and defeat some very powerful
enemies
listen i love jiu jitsu kaizen but love
beam
that's a little bit much you know either
way rika also seems to be able to copy
other curse techniques as she created a
megaphone
which held the cursed speech technique
within it and allowed for yuta to use it
freely
our final two imaginary vengeful curse
spirits
are tomino nomae and kuchi sake onna
both of which were controlled by ghetto
so i thought i'd couple them together
here
however each of them did not share the
same amount of time in the spotlight
unfortunately tamino no mai kind of
doesn't do
anything really before being defeated
kuchisakeona on the other hand
is pretty damn cool her innate technique
is scissors
she can create a set of scissors in her
hand and then create
and control a slew of giant scissors
around her opponent
which will try to cut off their limbs
and that
is horrifying and i love it finally she
can also create an innate domain which
locks her opponents within it until they
answer a question that she asks
if she doesn't like the answer the
domain will be dispelled and the
scissors will cut her target
immediately and done not gonna lie
didn't realize there were so many
special grade curses
in the series so far and i only really
covered the really important or
interesting ones on top of that
kinda feels like they aren't as special
as they let on
but i guess that is kind of the point
the series is trying to drive home
with the constant power creep of curses
in their world
they have this idea that special grade
curses are going to become the norm if
things continue to spin out of control
but
what do you guys think which cursed
spirit is your favorite
i'm pretty partial to chozo and rika
honestly
i just find them pretty damn cool and
mahito has his own
set of interesting traits which are
gross
but also very interesting but let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below
if you guys enjoy this jutsu kaizen
video and want to see more please leave
a like and if you're new to anime uproar
remember to subscribe and ring that bell
by selecting all notifications you can
help guarantee that you will not miss
any future videos with that being said
you can also follow anime uproar at
anime uproar on twitter and instagram or
myself at excellionyt
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible a special
thank you to the absolute mad lad and
disciple of lord twigo himself
alpha sigma and of course all of our the
one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans
ingrada pateh al-jital dr kortman
the toasted chi the spike 8227
emperor otaku spidey life tinel tungsten
tarcus
baked buddhist cody hebert and monkey d
quilly and of course i want to thank our
pro hero patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh the
red haired raven
angel cruz anatoly kozitsky very gucci
alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokami and water joanne
garcia
ted not ted fatboy games corey mcgowan
metal mama deadly saint soul ride slice
and dice
if you're enjoying our videos and feel
like they're adding some level of value
to your life
please consider supporting us over on
patreon even a dollar gives you access
to our patron exclusive discord
and we'll get your name in all of our
videos along with these fantastic people
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time
stay excellent
[Music]